ensuite s'il vous plaît à
savoir J ​​miss Burkart où avez-vous été
blessé en France je voulais dire où sur votre
corps il s'est fracturé le crâne pendant la guerre
quand ça arrive est tout
devient noir est flexible
je ne peux pas l'éloigner de la mort s'ils
s'ouvrent comme un cerveau il '  va me tuer
notre radiographie ne montre aucun signe de
fracture actuelle, nous avons donc un vétérinaire qui est
en parfaite santé,
le gars dit qu'il ne sait pas s'il est
réveillé ou s'il rêve, je veux dire le bon ami
Jorge Stephanie qui parle Je suis parti avec le
Mavi  depuis deux ans et si cela ne vous dérange pas,
j'aimerais savoir quelques choses sur
vous
quel est votre nom indien ou votre date de connexion
puis-je vous demander ce que c'est
tout le monde en parle combien de temps vous
restez ici allez
pour ne pas vous offenser mais les blancs ne
nous aiment pas beaucoup cela ne m'affecte pas du
tout
peu de temps après qu'ils en parlent je n'ai aucune
idée de
pouvoir fermer vara est de me dire la
première chose que vous visualisez le soleil n'est pas
mes petites fonctionnalités sont tout vous  J'ai besoin que les
Pieds-Noirs croient que Dame a prédit
l'avenir  nous pensons que les rêves éclairent un
peu le passé lorsque vous
nous retrouvez
[Musique]
si un homme ne prend pas ces choses au
fil du temps, elles s'accumulent
et un jour devient trop